dernier moment avant la rentrée famille
travail aux politiques pour angèle et sa
fille julie certaines valeurs sont
claires j'ai toujours toujours droite et
conservateurs mais pour la première fois
la femme d'affaires et grand mère a des
doutes
c'est là que je me commence à ma demande
m'a posé des questions avec qui je
devrais vraiment mettre mon sens même si
elle a voté pour lui
elle déplore les compressions de doc
faux dans l'éducation qui ont un impact
direct sur ses proches étudiantes ont
choisi firmi à l'université du livre
soit désormais 5000 dollars de moins par
année en prix et bourses
un dur coup pour cette mère
monoparentale angers droit créé
maintenant qu'un scénario semblable ne
se répète ou fédéral passe passe un jour
je suis beaucoup d'actes forts puis j'ai
pas j'ai pas vu 2 à 1 de recherche
sortir pu nous dire non d'abord
notariaux mais moi c'est pop art qu'est
ce que je peux faire de plus en plus et
populaire d'oxford est devenu l'armé
utilisée par justin trudeau depuis des
semaines pour attaquer un des chiens
les politiciens conservateurs que ce
soit d'oxford où d'autres à travers le
pays
d'abord proche de john ford andrew
scheer semble vouloir maintenant prendre
ses distances
les actions futures
sur le bord du lac simcoe l'été s'étire
mais l'élection fédérale du 21 octobre
n'est pas si loin le candidat
conservateur local est déjà à pied
d'oeuvre selon jack shipley ses
concitoyens sont surtout préoccupés par
leur qualité de vie
le conseiller municipal ne crois pas
qu'un effet d'oxford nui à ses chances
d'être élu pour lui les électeurs sont
capables de faire la différence entre
d'oxford et indochine
quoi qu'en dise justin trudeau ans j'ai
le droit
elle ne votera jamais libéral mais pense
à de nouvelles options
pourquoi juste parce qu'ils y pensent ça
va parler je trouve que beaucoup de ces
opinions sont les mêmes que les mialhe
lors de la dernière élection fédérale
les conservateurs l'avaient emporté ici
par seulement 86 vote s'ils veulent
garder leur siège
ils devront rassurer les électeurs
surtout ceux qui doutent depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de d'oxford ici
mathieu gaye et radio-canada père